même si je peux pas donner mon avis
j'adore ça et on va commencer par qui
bat par maître gims ouais alors j'en
viendrais clip je connais bien des
rapports privilégiés des maître gims les
rappeurs et des senteurs on sait le plus
célèbres de sa génération multipiste les
lunettes noires il a maigri il a maigri
la collection de vêtements toussa toussa
toussa
sauf que cette fois ci on parle du lit
pour autre chose parce qu'il fait
l'objet d'un documentaire sur netflix
qui est un documentaire qui a beaucoup
fait parler à juste titre on l'a suivi
ils l'ont suivi pendant un an
donc on découvre des pans de sa vie
qu'on ignorait absolument est donc bien
évidemment on va revoir les extraits les
plus forts avec par exemple sont arrivés
en france quand il s'appelait gandhi
joonas c'est comme ça qu'on dit on
imagine que vous êtes un puriste donc à
l'ail et il a deux ans il arrive du
zaïre et franchement les débuts n'était
pas facile ni pour lui ni pour sa
famille on regarde on est arrivé en
france en moins de van hamme aventure
vraiment pour des mois parce que tu
arrives au début tu peux prendre un
hôtel vite fait mais après tu as plus de
ressources quoi pas de travail et pas de
papiers machin et c'était une vraie
aventure
robert séguin beaucoup de pudeur par
rapport à ça d'entrée n'en parle pas
beaucoup
mon père aussi donc
mais je sais que je sais que c'était pas
c'était une question de vie ou de mort
vendre bien qu'il y ait levé le doigt je
ne peux pas ne pas lui donner la parole
oui alors je voulais juste revenir pour
eux sur la notion de rapport privilégié
c'est parce que oui et il ya le fort
longtemps fort fort longtemps
j'étais dans un clip avec lui pour ses
tubes bella et justement on me pose
souvent la question parce que j'ai un
truc en plus de ce reportage c'est qu'on
me dit souvent mais pourquoi tu veux
mettre quelques chars va pas gêner on va
regarder
[Rires]
oui c'est un phénomène qui est monté
noël cette femme était nommé mêle à la
fois de l'efama pays c'est tout achat
nous aiment et les hommes
avec les mais elle n'était pas d'ici
liban c'est difficile synonyme de
magnifiques att que des disques qui
devenait vite indécis comme des feuilles
de bien
de pousser mais
[Musique]
le soir
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à vos clics
les féministes me pardonne mais ça
s'appelle un avion de chasse n'est pas
parce que vous le fassiez je suis un peu
ému et ça me fait bizarre je crois avait
rajeuni depuis encore non ce que je
voulais dire c'est que c'est con depuis
ce clip on me pose souvent la question
mais pourquoi il porte toujours ses
lunettes pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi est
en fait moi je les trouvais la raison
pourquoi il n'est il porte ses lunettes
c'est parce qu'en fait au final il se
balade dans la rue sans ses lunettes
personne ne le reconnaît et ça c'est
juste dingue c'est que quand on a fait
le clip que ce soit à caen a fait la
promotion en france en espagne n'importe
où vous voulez il se balade sans ses
lunettes à l'aéroport n'importe où il
est méconnaissable
et ça c'est ma pourquoi marine on vous
met d'accord ces cons là ça en vidéo
après commence même pas blaguer je suis
pas d'humeur je te dis tout de suite
c'est pas avec un jus d'orange son calme
m d'un souci je faisais un freestyle
où j'ai mis des lunettes noires de
france a eu à tourner et les pas de base
on savait pas qui j'étais donc on a
commencé à m'appeler l'homme en vérité
les gens ils vont continuer à arriver
comme ça être fasciné par parce qu'on va
voir ses yeux le jour où je vais enlever
mes lunettes
ils vont dire tu aurais pas dû les
enlever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]